after 1945 across the continent ravaged
by war and famine Europe's people looked
for a way to rebuild for the future
displaced persons returned home or made
new homes as European town for many
centuries a handful of European leaders
decided that the best way to prevent war
as to shandur things which nations have
been fighting for and a little closer
bond a friendship and trust the first
step of the European Coal and Steel
community up years later the signature
of the Treaty of Rome led to the
creation of the European Economic
Community and laid the foundation to the
day's European Union the Treaty of Rome
take the way for a number of common
policies a common market was created
with the removal of borders and barriers
goods people capital and services it
allowed cross-border trade to flourish
making war between neighbors simply
unthinkable and generating prosperity
and opportunities for millions of
European citizens which they had not
known before putting in place these four
fundamental freedoms helped Europe's
economies developed and led to the
creation the world's biggest trading
bloc the Common Agricultural Policy was
also launched with the Rome treaty at a
time when Europeans knew what being
rationed and hungry meant they knew how
much food makes a difference between
life and death between good and poor
health over the last 60 years ensuring
that Europe is self-sufficient and that
we can secure our food and be sure of
what we eat has been a core priority of
the European Union after the Second
World War
Europeans wanted a strong social policy
aimed at sheltering the weakest and so
that Rome treaty established the
European Social Fund today over one
third of the EU budget is spent on
economic and social cohesion the
European Union was founded on coal and
steel today the European energy Union
will ensure that Europe has secured
affordable and climate friendly energy
why the use of our resources and greater
energy efficiency are key to fighting
climate change
and also to generating new jobs growth
and investment in Europe over time new
challenges emerged in Europe with
technological progress globalization and
several enlargement of the EU this calls
for an extension of the fundamental
freedoms into new domains in May 2015
the Commission launched a strategy for
creating a digital single market
providing people and companies with
better personal protections online and
creating the right conditions to
maximize the potential of the digital
economy in 2016 the presidents of the
European Commission jean-claude Juncker
called for a European pillar of social
rights in the euro area to address
crucial social challenges including
poverty and income inequality Commission
also created a European solidarity core
in 2016 to provide new opportunities for
young people in Europe over its 60 years
of existence the Treaty of Rome has
evolved the European Union and new
treaties have been needed to keep pace
of its growth and development the
history of the Union has been formed
under the guidance of this treaty is of
an unprecedented nature in Europe we are
looking back on over 70 years of peace
which our continent has never known
before
the journey has not always been smooth
it is a story of individuals and their
lives it is a story of institution and
their leaders of men and women working
tirelessly to overcome differences it is
the story of common values common goals
common standards and common policies
developed together leading to the
emergent for the stronger union between
European in a globalized world today
more than ever
United we can shake the world and secure
our place in it
you